it's good to know how things are
actually used in practice and he
certainly has a lot of experiences in
variables of optimization in practice
and so he's going to tell us about mixed
integer programming and some ideas that
are useful and use some of the arts and
what actually works and so on yeah thank
you so thank you for the invitation to
speak
she's a microphone on ok so I'm gonna
give a fairly broad overview how
effectively the take a very fairly broad
look at the question of how effectively
we can use multiple processors in
practice for solving LPS and MIPS linear
and mixed mature programming problems
just to make sure we're all starting on
the same page I'm sure this is familiar
to everyone I'll go quickly through it
an LP isn't optimization problem of the
four minimize C transpose X subject to
ax equals B X between lower and upper
bounds so I mean your objective linear
constraints mixed integer program of MIT
is an optimization problem of the same
form with the addition of a constraint
that some or all of the X J's can be
constrained to take integer values
binary values are most common but
arbitrary integrality restrictions are
fine all right if you look at LP and MIT
in practice there's really I mean
there's pretty substantial motivation
for trying to understand how to how to
do these well basically how to solve
large problems how to solve them quickly
they're really three important
characteristics that that these
approaches share they're broadly
applicable computationally demanding and
the solutions have significant financial
value millions of dollars potentially at
stake so I'm going to talk about each of
these in turn so on the topic of
applicability one thing we did was we
just took a list of all of our customers
for a one-year period
and tried to classify them by
application area so this is basically
2012 there are few that are in bold
actually those are maybe a bit harder to
see the bold ones are the ones that are
more common so electrical power energy
finance logistics and workforce
scheduling are more common but as you
can see it's an extremely broad set of
applications for the for the technology
this is just one year worth of
applications as far as the computational
demands of LP and MIT let me talk about
each of these in turn first I'll talk
about LP to talk about computational
demands it's useful to talk about the
actual algorithms that are used for LP
as you probably know there are two
primary algorithms there's the simplex
method and there's interior point or ya
a scuse me otherwise known as barrier
now so here's a trivial example this is
a problem in two variables with three
constraints plus the non-negativity of
the two variables and the blue region is
the feasible region for this problem and
the simplex method traverses vertices so
it moves from one vertex of the Pala
type to another along an edge in order
to improve the objective eventually it
reaches the an optimal vertex interior
point on the other hand traverses the
interior of the feasible region it's
[ __ ] could follow something called a
central path so the central path is
actually it's got fairly interesting
shape typically you can't follow it
directly so you do a you linearize you
basically use Newton's method so you
compute a step direction you do a
predictor step do a corrector step and
you repeat oops in this will and so
interior point method will eventually
reach a point that is near to the
optimal face it will actually reach a
point that's near to the middle of the
optimal face of the polytope of the LP
so in terms of computational demands LP
is actually mostly a solved problem so
if you if your goal is just to solve a
single LP problem it's extremely rare
that that presents a major challenge
there are few LP models that we've
gotten from customers that we just can't
solve but I can count them on probably
one hand however that doesn't mean that
LP itself is not a computational
bottleneck in particular LP is often
used as a subroutine and often times the
results of one LP solve are used as the
input to the next LP solve so let me
give a concrete example this is a model
called sgm it's a scheduled generation
model for an airline modest-sized about
150,000 rows 180,000 columns it's
actually a MIT model so if you look at
the LP relaxation of the MIT model the
the root node of the MIT took about 18
hours to solve this is actually a couple
years ago probably now now and be quite
a bit less but and then that solution of
course was a continuous solution didn't
obey the integrality restrictions but a
bit of branch and bound was enough to to
guide the solution towards feasibility
after 1700 nodes of branch and bound the
first feasible solution to the problem
was found with a 3.7 percent optimality
gap so the maximum improvement that
would be possible from this solution was
a bond founded 23.7%
which from the customer point of view
was an acceptable was an acceptable gap
so this was a an acceptable solution to
their problem well it wasn't acceptable
was the 92 days of runtime that was
required to reach this and so this is
this is an example where basically it's
it is a map but the bottleneck is just
solving a sequence of LPS so thus LP is
mostly a self problem from
computational point of view when it
comes to mixed integer programming
actually this is a partially a repeat of
what what Cindy did yesterday but um yes
actually typically it's numerical issues
just the lack of the basically the
inability to make forward into
consistent forward progress yes yeah so
when it comes to MIT the the the the
standard solution approaches of is a
branch and bound so you start off by
relaxing the integrality constraints
giving you a route relaxation you solve
that as an LP and the objective function
for that LP assuming we're assuming
minimization so the objective function
for that LP is going to be lower than
the objective for the for the optimal
integer solution clearly but the
relaxation has fewer constraints so if
we add the integrality constraints back
in it's going to make the it's going to
make the objective ORS so the LP
relaxation is presumably going to have
variables that that that are required to
take integer values in the in the so
it's the model is going to have integer
variables that do not take integer
values in the LP relaxation so in this
example in this example we have a
variable V which is constrained to take
an integer value in the relaxation takes
a value of 3.5 so your branch he branch
up you branch down you add additional
bounds and this in the in the left
branch be less than or equals three and
the right branch would be greater than
or equal four and you continue this
branch and bound process so that so each
of these sub problems here is emit
itself it's the same as the original NIP
but it has one additional bound and so
we just recurse so we take this problem
solve the relaxation choose an integer
variable that doesn't take an integer
value branch eventually one of three
things is going
to happen as you continue this process
one possibility is you may discover that
the relaxation at a particular node and
this branch and bound is integer
feasible all the integer values
variables take energy values that
becomes an your incumbent it becomes an
upper bound on the solution for this for
the for the min as you continue you can
you explore more nodes maybe you find
another node that has an integer
relaxation and that node has a better
objective value than your previous
integer solution so that becomes your
new incumbent you get a new upper bound
you may discover a branch in a branch
that the relaxation for a particular
node the objective value is worse than
the objective for these integers for the
best integer solution you found in which
case you can fathom that node you can
ignore that sub tree you may discover
that a sub tree is infeasible in which
case of course you can ignore that sub
tree as well at any point in the branch
and bound process you'll have a lower
bound which is going to be the objective
down for the worst sorry it's going to
be the worst relaxation value for any
unexplored node in your tree so
basically each at any point you have
what's called a frontier a set of
unexplored nodes and the node among
those that has the worst bound is
basically going to constrain your is
going to constrain your overall bound so
as the branch and bound progresses you
have an upper bound u over a lower bound
u of an optimality gap and as the as the
as the exploration continues the gap
shrinks eventually the gap reaches 0
that's a proof of optimality typically
people stop well before that so
typically they're content with a nonzero
optimality gap so MIT I probably don't
have to say this but MIT is definitely
not a solved problem so here's one
extreme example here's a customer model
with 44 constraints and 51 variables the
variables are all general integers
modest-sized problem
if you solve the root node it's fairly
easy to find the integer feasible
solution with objective 21 86 this is
found with the heuristic approach the
initial upper bound is 13 negative 13 79
0.4 you let this problem run for a day
day and a half
several million nodes several gigabytes
worth of tree data and the integer
solution and the lower bound do not
change in that time so oops so that's an
extreme case right so I should say that
this is this is unusual a problem of
this size is typically is typically
quite easy but I mean Amit this Amit is
np-hard so they're going to be cases
that are just extremely difficult so I
talked about generality I talked about
computational cost let me talk a bit
about financial impact
there are lots and lots of examples I
could give and I'll just I'll just give
I'll just give one here so the NFL
National Football League is a nine
billion dollar a year business and the
profitability of their nine billion
dollar your business is heavily
dependent on the solution to a single
mixed integer programming problem and
when I say a single problem I'm not
talking about solving a family of models
and I'm talking about solving a sequence
of models I'm talking about a single
instance one mitt model so what is it
what does this mitt model do this mitt
model determines the schedule which
teams play on which days you know which
one plays which ones play Monday night
football which plays which ones play
these time slots those time slots so the
schedule determines basically how many
people are going to watch the games
which determine how much they can charge
for advertising for the games which
determines how much the TV networks will
pay the NFL for the rights to carry the
games which has a tremendous impact on
their bottom line so this is one example
there are many other examples basically
LP and NIP have tremendous financial
impact
so if you look at the landscape so we've
got a technology that's broadly
applicable computationally demanding and
the solutions have significant financial
value in addition if you look at the
algorithms on the surface there are
actually some obvious sources of
parallelism so this seems like a recipe
for large-scale computing basically
throw lots of hardware at the problem
and as I'll discuss in the the reality
is that parallel computing has actually
had a pretty limited impact on the
practice of optimization so I'll talk
about parallelism in linear programming
first and then I will talk about
parallelism in mixed easier programming
so as I mentioned in linear programming
there are two different algorithms
typically used simplex and barrier let
me talk let me talk about the steps
associated with each of these algorithms
so in simplex the basic algorithm
maintains a basis which is a square
sub-matrix B of the constraint matrix a
so at any point the algorithm has a
basis and it has an Lu factorization of
the spaces in each iteration of the
simplex method you choose an entering
variable so you choose a variable that's
not currently in the basis we're
bringing that variable into the basis
would improve the objective function you
compute a direction vector which is
basically the the change in your current
X solution for each for each unit change
in the in the entering variable you
compute a step length it's called a
ratio test basically you determine how
far you can move in that direction
before one of the other variables hits
one of the affected variables hits one
of its bounds and then you bring the
entering variable in you take the
variable that hits it's bound you bring
it out you push it out and so when you
do this you get a new basis so you
update your basis you update your basis
Factory basically you you perform a
bunch of updates to account for the fact
that you've changed your basis and then
these updates accumulate periodically it
makes sense to just throw out the
updates and just refactor so you
is due a new Lu factorization of your
basis B so simplex in one slide the
barrier algorithm it's it's quite
different it actually solves a series of
weighted normal equations so in each
iteration you solve a linear system
involving the matrix a theta inverse a
transpose where a is your constraint
matrix theta is a diagonal matrix and
the and so the resulting matrix is a
positive definite symmetric positive
definite so this is these systems are
solve using Chi luskey factorization is
Jim yes oh yeah always
yes so the these are solved using the
linear systems are solved using actual
esky factorization and a forward and
backward solve so the first step in
barrier is to to compute a fill reducing
ordering so the the matrix that's
factored in each iteration has the same
structure each time and so you can
pre-compute this with this ordering once
this is to reduce the cost of the
factors raishin reduce the amount of
fill the results in the factorization
and then once you've computed this in
each iteration you form this a theta a
theta inverse a transpose matrix you
factor it you perform one or well
typically several solves involving the
factor matrices do a few ax and a
transpose X computations if you've
vector operations and then there's a
final step here which is called a cross
over step so the interior point method
remains in the interior for the entire
of it entirety of its execution and so
you never actually reach the the optimal
face so what the cross over step does is
it takes the final iterate which is
which is presumably quite near to your
optimal face and a transfer and it moves
to a vertex of the optimal phase and so
when you're all done with barrier you
have a basic solution it's really
impossible to tell once you've given if
you're given that solution whether
is computed by barrier simplex so for
any for any LP an MIT model there's
actually a first step which which I
haven't mentioned so far which is a pre
solid step basic notion here is that
optimization models LP and MIT models
are built by people or programs or what
have you they typically have some some
simple reductions that can be performed
on them things like variables that are
fixed so you know if a variable is fixed
to a particular value you don't want it
sitting in your constraint matrix you
just want to pull it out once at the
beginning and not have to deal with it
again constraints that are trivially
satisfied those can be those can be
removed equality's so if you have x
equals y plus c you may want to remove
the variable x and just replace it with
y plus c wherever it appears so there's
a list of pre solve reductions these are
basically just logical reductions you do
the problem to simplify it to make it
smaller so that the the simplex our
barrier algorithm have a smaller problem
to work with and then once simplex our
barrier computes a solution there's an
unprepped we take the solution to the
pre solved model you transform it to
this to a solution for the original so
if you look at the steps associated with
simplex and barrier in terms of
iteration simplex iterations are
incredibly cheap the basis matrices that
are factored in simplex frankly in most
cases they're mostly triangular and so
the Lu factorization of a nearly
triangular matrix is is quite cheap
triangular solves involving these
matrices these are the the vectors that
are being solved against our sparse the
matrices are extremely sparse so these
triangular solves are very cheap the
number of iterations you do in simplex
is you know order thousands order
millions depends on the problem but lots
and lots of cheap iterations that's the
that's the key point now when it comes
to barrier the iterations are much more
expensive this is a weighted set of
weighted normal equations on the full a
matrix not just on the on a basis matrix
however there are not nearly as many
iterations required so barrier the
typical iteration count is dozens 50 you
know maybe maybe a hundred in terms of
the sparse linear algebra and simplex as
I mentioned the triangular solves are on
very sparse matrices and the matrix
matrices are constantly changing so
we're constantly pivoting entries into
the bases pivoting entries out in
contrast for barrier the there's a
you're doing a choice key factorization
on a matrix with static structure so
stress key factorization can can exploit
dense kernels level three kernels so
this is a it's it's a much more amenable
to sort of high performance kernels
things like blas three that sort of
thing
so when it comes to parallelism for
simplex there's really no general
purpose parallel algorithm that's been
proposed there have been a few special
purpose simplex codes for matrices with
special structure even these haven't
been that successful but um in general
when it comes to just an arbitrary
matrix there's really nothing that's
been proposed for simplex when it comes
to barrier if you look at the
computational bottlenecks you gotcha
less key factorization it's well known
how to do parallel obsolesce key
factorization triangular solves even
that you can paralyze matrix vector
multiplies even the ordering there
there's parallelism in the ordering so
lots of opportunities for parallel
computing
so let's compare the performance of
these two approaches on a set of models
so this is on a set of 1242 test model
basically we receive models from
customers we collect them we create it
we have our own internal test set so
some of these are public benchmarks some
of these are models that people have
sent to us and just just to create a
reasonable test set basically we throw
out we threw out the models that were
too easy or too hard you know to what it
was this meat was too easy and too hard
I mean we just arbitrarily said that any
model where both barrier and simplex can
solve it in less than point zero one
seconds it's it's not even worth it's
not even worth trying to measure and
just to keep the just to keep the the
test tractable any model where neither
of the two algorithms can solve it in
two hours we just we just exclude it
leaves leaves about 810 models then what
we do is we run simplex on the model we
were on barrier in the model we take the
run time ratio and then take the
geometric mean across that full set of
models and given what I've said so far
you might expect barrier to win by a
large margin given the fact that it this
test is run on a fork or machine there's
just a modern it's basically a PC a
latest version of grow be running on a
quad-core i7 3770k barrier uses four
cores and we include the time for the
crossover simplex uses one we do we use
dual simplex here there's actually a
primal simplex and a dual simplex
basically primal simplex uses the
simplex algorithm on the original
problem as stated essentially dual
simplex dual eyes as the problem it
applies simplex for that dual model but
the dual ization is implicit so dual
simplex for various reasons is much much
faster than primal simplex so dual
simplex is the sort of the default
simplex choice and we just arbitrarily
set the dual simplex as the baseline so
the geometric mean of simplex versus
itself is 1.0 and what you see is
barrier is about five percent faster on
average on this set
however dual wins
often the barrier does so no better this
is actually a function of the notion of
what is a model that's too easy
so barrier there's a fair amount of
start-up cost associative barrier
basically do support you know you do
pre-ordering basically you are paying a
start-up cost in barrier which which is
not so big in simplex so as the problem
so as the problems get more difficult so
as we vary the notion of what what makes
a problem too easy from 0.01 seconds to
0.1 second or 1 second barrier actually
starts to pull ahead so you can see this
is so the first line here was the number
from the previous slide and then as we
get down to one second barrier here is
winning nearly twice as often as dual
simplex but not always and on average
it's about a factor two faster in
simplex and so based on what I've said
so far you may conclude that this is a
result of the fact that barrier can
exploit parallelism that it can make use
of multiple cores and that's actually
not really the main part of the the main
part of the explanation so that the the
explanation is more related to this
chart right here so what this shows is
peak double precision gigaflops for
several generations of processors these
are just you know cheap desktop
processors latest generations so going
back to 2001 Pentium 4 it's 2008 2011
2013 what you see is a pretty impressive
improvement in the peak double-precision
floating-point for these for these chips
and the computational colonel in barrier
is a is basically a blas 3 is a
matrix-matrix multiply so it gets a
substantial fraction of the peak
performance and so even in the last 5
years the performance here this is a 4
core chip
this is a latest you know has well for
courtship the performance has increased
by a factor 10 whereas if you look at
simplex performance generally simplex
performance scales with the clock speed
roughly and so in this five-year period
from 2008 to 2013 the clock speed has
gone from 2.4 to 3.5 gigahertz so we're
talking about a factor 10 improvement in
the capability these chips for the
computational kernel a barrier and less
than a factor 2 for simplex in the same
period sure
so actually so going back to the
question of thread level parallelism
basically core level parallelism how
much parallel speed it are we getting
for in the in the barrier solver what
you see is maybe a bit surprising so for
two cores on average we're getting about
1.2 9x 4 cores 1.5 1x and 12 cores only
1.7 X so what's what's going on here so
when we look at this is to look at a
breakdown of where run time is spent so
these are fractions of total run time so
for example pre solve on one run on four
cores over this set of models that take
more than one second pre solve on
average takes about 12% a total run time
and these are the top five consumers at
run time in the barrier solver and what
you see is that indeed on four cores
factorization is the number one item and
the number one consumer runtime but
crossover is just behind it and then on
12 cores factorization has actually
fallen off quite a bit
and crossover has has increased quite a
bit so I haven't said to this point what
crossover is what the algorithm is and
well the algorithm is basically simplex
it's just it's a special case of simplex
there are a few steps and simplex that
can be skipped but basically you have a
basic current basis your pivoting
variables in your pivoting variables out
your maintaining Lu factorizations doing
basis updates it's it's simply from a
from a computational point of view it
looks just like simplex and so oh you're
talking about these two yeah it's
actually the I would you you've stated
it in a sort of asymptotic way it's more
a constant factor thing I mean the the
factorizations are running at you know
100 100 150 gigaflops whereas the solves
are running at you know 120th 150th of
that yeah right exactly
and so that you know there are some
constant factors any actually that that
comes into the next slide so let me let
me show you let me show the next slide
so again all the results here are
relative to our notion of what
constitutes a model that's too easy to
consider as part of the benchmark so
what I've done here is varied again
varied the notion of what's too easy
instead of so we started at point zero
point zero one second was it point zero
one seconds we moved up to one second
now we're going all the way up to 100
seconds and as you might expect the the
bottlenecks are going to shift as you
move to more difficult models and indeed
the cost of the factorization relative
in particular to the solves has
increased however the biggest shift is
happening in the in the crossover so
basically what's happening is this this
you'll thing this simplex thing is
coming to dominate and so when we talk
about barrier versus simplex it's not
really a it's not really a direct
comparison its simplex versus barrier
with some simplex so simplex is really
simplex is really the computational
bottlenecks in both cases and you could
reasonably be you could reasonably ask
well do I do absolutely need to do
crossover why can't I just take the
interior solution and you could
empirically what we find is that
basically people these the interior
solutions are just not actionable you
just can't put them into into practice
simple sort of simple explanation is a
basic solution most of the variable sit
at bounds so in particular if your
bounds are just lower bounds on the
variables most of your variables are
going to be sitting at 0 so if you know
if you're if you're coming up with a
plan for a factory or an allocation of
resources whatever you what this is
going to give you a compact set of
actions where as an interior point
solution none of the variables are
sitting at abound the solution is is in
the interior of the polytope and so
these are just the there there are many
reasons why people just don't can't act
on these solutions and need a basic
solution yes
so I mean the Algar the dispersed linear
algebra and the algorithm exploits that
so a constraint that is not active
corresponds to a slack variable being in
the basis and a slack variable in the
basis basically that just that just
takes a portion of the basics basis and
makes it the identity matrix which from
a linear algebra point of view doing you
know doing factorizations and solves and
such on an identity matrix is uh is
awfully quick well you I mean you do you
you do but the dimension reduction just
comes from the fact that there's a large
portion of the matrix that's an identity
matrix and so effectively it's not it's
not complicating it's it's not
participating in any of the expensive
sparse linear algebra stuff
yeah I mean it's it is an empirical
there you can construct matrices that
that behave badly
absolutely so it's it's it is an
empirical statement but it's it's nearly
Universal okay so when it comes to
parallelism in LP so the benefits for
barrier tale off pretty quickly actually
but there is another way to exploit
parallelism it's fairly simple it's
basically it's concurrent optimization
when you've got multiple algorithms to
solve the same problem just start a
horse race start all the algorithms the
first one that finishes wins if you look
at computational results again this is
on a four core system in this case we're
going to use three cores for barrier and
one core for dual simplex and the the
geometric mean here comes down from
point four nine for barrier alone to
0.38 so a pretty substantial improvement
here of course this is not a recipe for
massive parallelism we've only got
because we've only got three different
algorithms for solving these LPS primal
simplex dual simplex and barrier and
primal is actually sufficiently worse
than dual that adding it to the mix
doesn't really buy you anything so this
is a way to get two-way parallelism
alright so I'm going to talk about mixed
in your programming now so on the
surface when it comes to mixtures of
programming it's embarrassingly parallel
you got a search tree you got a bunch of
nodes and the frontier these nodes are
independent you can farm them off to
multiple processors what's the problem
if you look at the reality so here are
results from a industry standard test
set to MIT bleib 2010 set of models that
are collected we've collected to try and
to be representative of the models that
people actually solving what you see is
on four cores average improvement is 2
point 2 point 2 X 12 cores 3 point 3 X
so some some speed-up from parallel but
nothing nothing like what you'd expect
given
given the embarrassing parallel picture
I showed in the previous slide so here's
another way of looking at the speed-up
results I'm sorry I should say that
there are actually several factors that
come into play that limit the
parallelism for nip I'm actually going
to talk about just one is this one's the
easiest to understand it's it's probably
the most intuitive it is probably the
most severe as well so if you look at
parallel speed ups across the model so
these are number of nodes explored on
the x axis parallel speed-up on the y
axis each point represents a single
model in that set of 87 and what you see
is four models that explore fewer than a
thousand nodes the parallel speed-up is
non-existent and this this set
represented this represents about a
third of the models in the set and you
know that intuitively this makes sense
basically the parallelism the source of
the parallelism is the nodes of the tree
there aren't that many knobs there's not
that much parallelism as you increase
the number of nodes the the parallelism
increases you notice that there's
actually a fair amount of noise in these
results here so for any for any one node
count you may see a pretty broad
spectrum of results let me just comment
on that briefly so one thing that's
inherent in solving mixed integer
programming problems no matter how no
matter how you look at them no matter
what you do is no it is random noise let
me let me show you one result here so
there's a there's a model 60w a 0 1 or
if you solve it using default settings
the runtime is 509 seconds if you change
a parameter you set the seed parameter
to 2 runtime is 23 seconds so 22-fold
speed-up what does this parameter doing
it's just changing the random number
seed so the nature of mixed is you're
programming there are variety decisions
that have to be made in order to solve
the mixed integer programming problem
you have to decide which variable to
branch on which cuts to generate which
heuristics to
variety decisions that that must be made
and oftentimes the criteria that are
used to make these decisions basically
if you're considering multiple
candidates it's a tie
so you basically break these ties
arbitrarily a different random number
seed gives you different tie breaking
which sends you down a completely
different path and sometimes the one
path is radically better or radically
worse than another and so so in this
particular case I didn't change anything
other than the random number seeds so
same model same processor can't count
same algorithm same everything just a
random number seed so you you can
imagine if you change anything at all it
introduces a substantial noise component
so let me go back to the previous set of
numbers let me look at let me present
them in a different way so again one
point per model in the data set in this
case the x-axis shows the fraction of
the run time that's spent at the root
node when run on one processor so one
point o means all of the time was spent
at the root node down here means of
small fraction again what you see of
course is that if you spend a large
fraction of your run time at the root
node there's not going to be a lot of
opportunities for parallel assuming that
there's no assuming that you can't
paralyze the route effectively you know
I'll get back to that um
what's perhaps more interesting is if
you look at the the full set of models
for the majority of models they're
spending a significant fraction of total
time at the road node so you know if
you're just just a simple Amdahl's law
computation says that if you're spending
twenty percent of your total run time at
the root node then your maximum speed-up
is going to be a factor of five sure
so yeah that so the peak the fraction of
run time was measured on P equals one
but the speed ups here were measured for
p equals 12
their ratios so 10 X 10 X 8 X in some
cases yeah I mean that's that's that
noise component coming into play right
and so you know clearly not all nodes
are created equal if all if all the
nodes have the same cost then all you'd
need is a hundred nodes to get a 1% to
have 1% of your time spent at the root
so clearly there's some pretty expensive
things happening at the root node so
search tree looks more like this so
what's happening at the root node so a
lot of things presov
as I mentioned root relaxation solutions
so you have to solve through taxation as
an LP and the the solution at the root
is much more expensive than the solution
at the nodes because at the root you
have to start the solution from scratch
where is it the nodes all you've done
from a node to its child is changed one
bound and simplex can reoptimize
quite quickly so that's a lot faster
than solving from scratch at the root
node you're generating cutting planes
you're generating you applying
heuristics to try and find feasible
solutions solutions to satisfy the
integrality constraints symmetry
detection branch variable selection
there's a long list of things that are
done at the root node and the list keeps
getting longer as the technology
improves and the basic motivation for
doing all these things at the root node
is if there's something that's true
about the problem you're better off
discovering it once at the root node
then rediscovering it at every node in
the branch and bound tree so let me give
you an example this is an example of a
cutting plane it's actually if it fits
the theme of the kind of one of the
minor themes of the conference it's
triangle detection so imagine you have a
set of a binary variables XY and Z you
have a set of constraints X plus y less
than or equal 1 y plus Z less or equal 1
and X plus Z less than or equal 1 so
these are pairwise incompatible
incompatibility constraints one of these
two variables has to be 0 okay if you
look at at the relaxation solution a
solution where all your variables take a
value 0.5 is feasible however if you
have a set of variables that are
pairwise incompatible then clearly only
one among that whole set can be chosen
and so this constraint is actually valid
X plus y plus Z less than or equal one
is valid for this problem and this this
constraint here cuts off this solution x
equals y equals y equals 0.5 and so in
general what cutting planes do is that
they add redundant constraints to the
problem problems that the constraints
that don't change the set of feasible
integer solutions but change the set of
feasible continuous solutions to get a
tighter relaxation a relaxation that
more closely matches the set of integer
feasible solution and the process of
adding cutting cutting planes you solve
the relaxation you add a set of cutting
planes to cut off that root solution
value you resolve in respecting those
cutting planes you cut that you cut that
solution off you you repeat this process
there are 13 different cutting plane
routines in guro B and so this process
is basically it's and turns out that's
that finding these violated cutting
planes is actually cheap the expensive
part is react amaizing and that's
simplex another thing we do at the root
node is symmetry detection so it turns
out it's quite common in mixed integer
programming problems to have
automorphisms to have permutations that
basically map the model back to itself
so given a given a model C transpose X
ax less than or equal B an autumn ilysm
is a row permutation in comment per
mutation that map's the constraint
matrix
the objective vector and the
right-hand-side back to itself so what
can you do with these with this
information well you can do a lot of
things sort of probably the simplest
thing to to to imagine is let's say
you're in in the middle of a
branch-and-bound search you visit a node
and you discover that the node you're
you're visiting is isomorphic to a node
that you've already visited so that
means that every solution that is
derived from that node that that that
you find in the subtree rooted at that
node is is going to be isomorphic to a
solution that's that's that would be
found by exploring the other node and so
there's actually no reason to explore
both of these sub trees you can just
explore one of the sub trees and you can
find all the solutions in the other sub
tree just by applying permutations to
the solutions you found in the original
sub tree and of course in order to
exploit this you need to identify these
automorphisms so there's a you know
they're algorithms for doing for finding
graph isomorphism they're they're not
cheap and if you're going to exploit
this information you're gonna have to
find these automorphisms at the root
node so an obvious question at this
point is you know if you're if you're
working in parallel there are all these
things that are happening at the root
node are they really you know are they
really essential ok is it is it
reasonable to consider just skipping
these steps and just assuming that using
multiple processors will make up for any
potential loss and in fact I'm gonna
argue that the trend is actually moving
in the opposite direction so even in the
presence of parallelism the amount of
work associated with solving missions or
programming problems is moving the work
associate is moving to the root and away
from the nodes so let me let me talk a
bit more about this so I'll just am i
doing on time I'll just go through this
quickly so this these are MIPS speed-up
numbers going from 2009 to the present
this is for a set of MIT models that
take more than
seconds what we're doing is we're
computing version diversion improvements
for various versions of our product and
I should just just to say none of these
none of these versions of the product
were behind the state-of-the-art so this
is this is not us catching up this is
really the the progress of the state of
the art and so if you look at the
cumulative improvement over models that
take more than 100 seconds for this
five-year period it's basically a factor
21 average improvement in our ability to
solve models that take more than 100
seconds okay so the technology keeps
improving there are a variety of factors
that come into play when it comes to the
improvements in the in the product one
factor that does not come into play as
we haven't figured out how to solve
nodes faster so simple process of
deduction if we are not solving nodes
any faster and we're solving problems
much faster that means we're solving
fewer nodes so basically the amount of
work that's being done in the nodes is
shrinking
so as the technology improves the
opportunities for parallelism by
exploiting the nodes the the size of the
tree are decreasing so where are there
increasing opportunities for parallelism
and myth well one opportunity is
concurrent nip this is a basically it's
a similar idea to concurrent LP so in
the case of LP we had multiple different
algorithms we set up a horse horse race
whichever one finished first one in the
case of nip we don't really have
different algorithms but we have
different strategies within the
algorithm so you can certainly imagine
on one core exploiting strategy that is
more aggressive on cutting planes
another core less aggressive more
heuristics less heuristics different
branch variable selection you know
there's a long list of strategies that
are there employed
that's your reading ahead it's that's so
the it turns out that the most effective
strategy we've found so far is in fact
just to set up different random number
generator in member seeds so just fire
off multiple machines same exact
strategies same exact model same exact
everything the only difference being
different random number seed for each
machine as you might imagine this
approach does have its limits so you're
not gonna get it this is not gonna be an
effective way to use a thousand a
thousand cores but on five cores across
this myth live set four models that take
more than 100 seconds get a 1.7 2x
average improvement in performance
starts a tail off so if you so if you
use 25 machines the improvement is only
one point eight nine X
so when it comes to so so far I've
really only talked about I've looked at
averages across sets of models and the
picture is not so encouraging when you
look across these sets but there are
definitely models where large search
trees are explored and you know in order
to solve the best known approaches to
solving these problems require you to
just plow through hundreds of thousands
or millions of nodes and so I just
wanted to say that this simple
distributed scheme is embarrassingly
parallel aspect of NIP sometimes works
and so here our results for a
distributed memory version this is a a
just a bunch of machines sitting on an
Ethernet nothing this is not a
supercomputer or anything like that so
on four machines for this set of three
models that require these models require
order you know order one to ten million
nodes to solve so on four machines and
eight machines we get nearly linear
speed-up things start to trail off at
about sixteen machines there are no
doubt you know problems that require
hundreds of millions or billions of
nodes that would that would be able to
exploit more machines but again this is
not you know this is going to get us to
they're gonna get us to order
dozens of machines it's not going to get
us to thousands of machines so actually
to conclude there are we have customers
who are literally begging us to give
them a solution for you know huge models
that they'd like to solve and they're
willing to you know buy whatever
hardware it takes the data is there I
mean they're generating huge models the
money's there so the the financial value
of solutions to these models is
substantial is enough that they're
willing to buy whatever hardware it
takes to solve these problems
and but you know despite whatever what
on the surface seem like pretty obvious
sources of parallelism if you dig a bit
deeper you discover that they're not so
obviously general-purpose and in fact
despite these sources of parallelism
really pale computing has played a
fairly modest role we're talking speed
ups in the you know two to five x
certainly not the tens or thousands that
ideally you would hope for with parallel
computing so that's it thank you
I mean it depends so it depends on the
algorithm so for barrier generally it's
gonna for barrier it for the for the
barrier durations it's gonna really
depend on the essentially the density of
factor matrix the the number of
iterations and barriers is a nearly
constant and so yeah the the run time is
going to be determined by the cost of
solving the system just a particular
machine well right right it was just so
it the the set was chosen in a way we
which we tried to be careful not to bias
it towards one or the other but you know
the sets were basically chosen by run
time on a particular machine
you know excluding models where either
algorithm took more than a certain time
it's just
it's so unfortunately so problem
dependent so in that there are like
there are classes of problems wherein
barrier you can characterize the the
growth rate and it's it's absolutely
superlinear
but when it comes to simplex there's
actually there's very little theory
about iteration council it's so problem
dependent well I mean for love these
problems they have substantial network
structure and so you know the the Lu
Factory of a network problem is you know
strangulate for the basis of a network
problem so the factorization is going to
be it's going to be linear in the number
of edges right sure sure but you know
they're varied so they're very few pure
network problems there's always some
sort of side constraint and
there hasn't been that much work in
trying to characterize you know exactly
what the you know what are what are
importing classes of side constraints
that sort of thing
crossover yeah both so yeah there are
really I'd say there are two modes so
mode number one is just degeneracy so
you've got a very high dimension face
optimal face and so in fact in order to
move to a vertex you basically wind up
not not much better off than if you just
started simplex from an arbitrary vertex
and yeah there are definitely other
cases where you where you wind up with
an ill-conditioned basis so you're you
you you try and find that you have to
you have to start with a guess at a
basis and if that guessed basis is
ill-conditioned and these pivots
basically you wind up introducing more
and more area until eventually you walk
you're at a point where your basis
doesn't really capture any of the
information that was contained in the
interior in the initial interior
solution so both of those both of those
can happen we wrote our own well there's
some special properties in interior
point which which we exploit which don't
which make it harder to just go and use
in a package